وصل الرئيس الإيراني إلى دمشق لإجراء
محادثات مع الرئيس السوري باشا
الأسد، وفقًا لما ذكرته
وسائل الإعلام الرسمية الإيرانية، وتمثل الرحلة أول
زيارة دولة لرئيس دولة إيراني إلى
دمشق منذ بدء الحرب الأهلية السورية
قبل 12 عامًا،
وسينضم إلينا بشير آخر، لذلك أنا  يعني الكثير من الأشياء التي يجب
النظر إليها هنا، الديناميكيات
مثيرة للاهتمام، نعم
بالتأكيد، سوريا ظلت إيران حليفًا
قويًا للرئيس بشار
الأسد حيث تقدم
الدعم العسكري والمالي الحاسم، وهذه
إشارة واضحة من إيران إلى أنهم سيستمرون في
الحفاظ على ذلك بل وتعزيزه.
العلاقة بين إيران وسوريا
وسمعنا من وسائل الإعلام الرسمية
أن إبراهيم راسي الرئيس في إيران
سيسعى إلى
إعادة تأسيس وتعزيز تلك
العلاقات مع سوريا مع التركيز على التجارة
والاقتصاد وبالطبع على
العلاقات السياسية والدبلوماسية.  بين البلدين،
سيسافر مع وفد رفيع المستوى
وسيجتمعون
وكذلك مع الرئيس بشار، وتحدثت مع
مسؤولين سوريين آخرين بالإضافة إلى قضاء بعض
الوقت خلال هذه الزيارة التي تستغرق يومين للقاء
رجال الأعمال الإيرانيين والسوريين
الموجودين حاليًا في سوريا.  بالإضافة إلى زيارة
بعض المواقع الدينية في البلاد
وبالطبع خلفية كل هذا
مثيرة للاهتمام للغاية، حيث يحدث هذا بينما
تخرج سوريا بشكل أساسي مما
كان حالة طويلة من العزلة عن
جيرانها الإقليميين، حيث يقوم المسرح العربي
ببناء إعادة بناء تلك
العلاقات تدريجيًا  ومع الحكومة السورية،
شهدنا أيضًا قيام إيران بالطبع
بتعزيز علاقاتها مع
جيرانها العرب. وفي شهر مارس فقط، رأينا
اتفاقًا مهمًا يتم التوصل إليه بين
المملكة العربية السعودية وإيران لإعادة تأسيس
تلك العلاقات هناك، لذلك يعد هذا
تطورًا مهمًا للغاية، فهو  إنها
المرة الأولى التي نرى فيها
الرئيس الإيراني يزور البلاد منذ أكثر من
عقد من الزمن